[Música]
el municipio de san carlos
conocido también como la costa dulce del
oriente antioqueño
es un territorio hermoso donde hay tres
centrales hidroeléctricas que hacen
parte de todo un anillo energético
que genera a su vez el 33 por ciento de
la energía en nuestro país
pero por un lapso
de dos décadas
se registraron en ese territorio 33
masacres
y fueron expulsados del territorio
20.000 de sus 25.000 habitantes claro
alrededor de 800 homicidios más de 200
desaparecidos un registro de 137
víctimas civiles de minas antipersonas
hay violencia sexual hay reclutamiento
de menores y eso a cargo de todos los
actores que hicieron parte de este
conflicto
después de esa horrible noche como se lo
pueden imaginar dónde no fui ajena
pues de mi familia fueron asesinados
seis de mis seres queridos
después d
perder algunos la peor parte es cuando
son asesinados nuestros hijos y dos de
ellos me los arrebataron
nos quedaban dos caminos o nos
quedábamos arrastrándonos en el odio el
dolor la venganza el resentimiento
o por el contrario
decidíamos
para darnos para
e iniciar un camino que nos permitiera
afrontar esa triste realidad
porque no solamente a mí se puede decir
que el 100 por ciento de la población de
nuestro municipio terminó haciendo
siendo afectada de una u otra manera
pero terminó siendo afectada
y es ahí cuando tomamos la decisión de
encontrarnos
para
recuperarnos mirándolos a los ojos
tomando los de las manos y por qué no
abrazando nos dirán ustedes y quién es
pues toda la población afectada pero
también aquellos que acababan de llegar
de dejar las armas de la guerra saben
por qué porque logramos entender
que de uno y otro lado lo único que
había era un poco de dignidades heridas
que los intereses de una u otras lógicas
había colocado a unos a otros para que
los causarán daños
iniciamos ese proceso de escucha activa
de tertulias de encuentros de charlas de
encontrarnos en las cafeterías para
mirarnos a los ojos y pensar qué futuro
queríamos de inmediato fueron llegando
algunas instituciones ongs y comunidades
que nos fuimos arriesgando darnos la
posibilidad de recuperar nuestra
dignidad pero también de recuperar la
dignidad de esos espacios donde el
horror y la muerte se había empoderado y
efectivamente
'logramos había una casa y luego fue un
hotel y terminó siendo un comando
paramilitar donde sucedieron todos los
vejámenes de la guerra y entre ellos la
desaparición de una niña de 15 años que
había marcado enormemente el territorio
y lo último que se sabía de ella era que
había sido entrada a ese lugar por esos
actores pues acompañando esa madre y en
compañía de muchos otros coterráneos nos
centramos allí
a buscar porque ya quedo en el
imaginario que como allí había estado
todo el horror de la guerra en la parte
de atrás en su solar pues según la
información había un cementerio
clandestino
se creó la necesidad de verificar esa
información e ir y arar la tierra arañar
la tierra buscando y preguntándole a la
tierra si allí reposaba de esos restos
fuimos empoderando nos de ese lugar
y haciendo los procesos ciudadanos de
participación de escucha
hoy por fortuna funciona allí ya es un
lugar de encuentro amplio donde se fue
al transformarse se convierte en el
centro de emprendimiento unidos por san
carlos donde las diferentes líneas de
productividad allí tienen su asiento
administrativo se inicia todo un proceso
de desminado que nos permitió devolver
descontar de esa deshonrosa cifra que
les dije desplazados o ya tenemos de
regreso retornados alrededor de 13.500
claro porque al terminar hay condiciones
de seguridad
y han logrado y subiendo en la línea de
productividad a través de esos mismos
procesos de ganadería piscicultores
apicultores madereros mineros
artesanales y ahí también funciona
nuestro centro el centro de acercamiento
para la reconciliación y la reparación a
través del cual y con el apoyo de iu y
acompañando a los jóvenes de un proceso
muy bonito de conciencia colectiva nos
hemos dado la tarea de que conozcan la
historia al igual que ustedes que la
reconozcan así algún día logran
comprender qué fue lo que pasó en este
tsunami humano con el ánimo de que nunca
jamás se vuelva a repetir porque las
consecuencias ya nos han quedado claras
ahora la tarea es evitar que esto se
repita y evitar que hayan más niños que
crezcan huérfanos como fue mi caso que
nos toque levantar hijos huérfanos como
me tocó con mi primera guía pero lo que
es peor aún que nos arranquen esos
pedazos del corazón como son nuestros
hijos y eso es lo que quisiéramos que
jamás volviera a suceder
es por ello que trabajamos hombro a
hombro y nos abrazamos con aquellos que
piensan diferente y hemos encontrado
otra forma de relacionarnos
en las diferencias hay quieren ser las
no es malo el que piensa diferente
simplemente eso diferente a mí en gustos
en costumbres en intereses
pero hay que desmitificar ese miedo que
nos deja instaurado un monstruo después
de que nos han dañado o en quien nos ha
dañado finalmente recuerdan un cúmulo de
dignidades heridas que entre todos nos
podemos encontrar reencontrar y mirarnos
a los ojos para poderla sanar
en la parte de atrás donde les dije que
sí
se tenía la información que era un
cementerio hace poco
decidimos transformarlo y construimos
una maloca hermosa casa madre donde se
vienen efectos estos encuentros
para poder que entendamos ese pasado y
le demos un pleno decente a ese futuro
que es lo único que tiene lógica
me sentaba recién reintegrada a la
población allá en el año en el 2005 2006
2007 me sentaba con ellos a intercambiar
a escucharnos sin juzgar lo que nos
escucharon desde los dolores y las
culpas y logramos entender
al pasado y así querramos no podemos
hacerle nada es el futuro el que merece
toda la atención
y que la vida no se hace tan interesante
por la cantidad claro la cantidad no
genera comodidad de poder adquisitivo
pero es interesante es cuando logramos
apreciarla y darle calidad
finalmente aquí vinimos fue a ser
felices y para ser feliz se necesita muy
poco
y consideró que aún a pesar de las
afectaciones se las comparó me pasé una
tractomula por encima y me piden un
dedito y eso fue suficiente para
levantarme ayudar con mi comunidad para
que nos levantáramos hoy tenemos una
ruralidad próspera y lo que parece es
que mi municipio es un municipio super
abundante en flora fauna aguas
cristalinas hermosas cascadas
y así nos enamoremos día a día y que
sabemos nuestras heridas liberemos
nuestras tristezas para poder darle
color a ese territorio y también abrir
los brazos para que ustedes todos
la oportunidad de conocerlo pues hoy en
el marco de la nueva industria del
turismo está potencializado en él como
primer renglón de la economía buscando
la sostenibilidad pero sobre todo
enmarcando en los buenos recuerdos de
los que ya no están y entendiendo que
acá vinieron a dejarnos un mensaje
supremamente positivo que algún día
partieron muy temprano de nuestro lado y
no vamos a seguir respirando venganza ni
odios sino por el contrario que sean
ellos el motor y el propósito para salir
adelante y para que nuestros jóvenes
nuestros niños puedan vivir en una
colombia totalmente diferente y quedan
todos invitados para que nos visiten con
buenos turistas a ese territorio hermoso
que no se arrepiente sabe cómo lo
llamamos la prendería porque el que pasa
de 3 meses a ya se queda
que dios los bendiga
[Aplausos]